Sand worms are gross, looking little things,
maybe a little bit cute. I almost feel bad using them as bait.
What if instead of us hunting them,
they were able to hunt us.
Could they make it from water onto land?
How much food would they need to sustain themselves?
And what's so unusual about the way they eat you.
This, what if,
and here's what would happen if sand worms were the size of humans,
you might find sand worms gross, but they're nothing to be afraid of.
Usually that is sand worms live in deep tunnels
at the bottom of the seat where they pray on lugworms and some small
bivalves,
the way they hunt and eat their prey is pretty terrifying.
We're lucky that they don't get larger than 80 centimeters in length,
because if they did well, you'd better see for yourself.
The most horrifying thing about a sand worm is its big strong
jaw,
sand worms use it to grab onto poor victims.
And this thing that comes out of its mouth is part of the digestive
tract. Yeah, they can push it outside of their bodies.
Ooh.
The good thing is sand worms are omnivores,
which means they eat both plants and animals.
That's good because if they were carnivores,
they for sure would want to eat you.
But now there might be a slight chance. You'd be safe.
Naturally sand worms are very introverted.
They don't like to leave their burrows.
Splash giant sand worms would be good swimmers.
They mostly feed on algae and scavenge fish in smaller Marine animals,
even birds that hunt near shallow waters might become dinner.
And what about people?
Most likely human sized sand worms wouldn't eat humans that
often just try not to make them angry,
but this doesn't mean you'd be completely safe.
Sand worms don't have eyes.
They couldn't see you when they were searching for food.
So they could accidentally bite you because of their
increased size sand worms would need to consume more food.
They might leave their home waters of the Antarctic and Arctic oceans and
spread further across the planet.
They might even have to evolve and move on to land.
So as not to become extinct the most time would be
during their mating season when they leave their burrows.
But not because they'd be out and about.
They'd have other things on their mind. If you know what I mean,
it would be dangerous because larger predators would travel to shallow waters to
feed on them.
Some beaches would be off limits and would have to post warnings about the sand
worms. If they became too much of a problem,
humans might decide to reduce the sand worm population.
And didn't I tell you not to make them angry.
Hunting sand worms would do precisely that they might
want to get their revenge.
If a sand worm was coming after you,
it would happen in the water unless we're talking about giant evolved
sand worms that would live on land, but more on that in a minute,
a sand worm would grab you with its strong jaw.
Its mouth would be full of sharp teeth and the bite would be excruciating.
A sand worm. That's bigger than you might try to swallow.
You hit wouldn't chew you much. So you'd end up in its wreaking,
slippery crop right away.
That's where worms temporarily store their food.
You might still be conscious and in a lot of pain in the worms
gizzard, you'd get ground up together with ingested sand.
If you were to escape, you'd better do that.
Now while you still might be able to cut your way out with a sharp object,
if not,
you'd move through its intestine where all your nutrients would be absorbed,
whatever was left of you would be cooped up. Well,
let's just hope that sand worms wouldn't evolve into spice producing
750 meter long thick skin desert living giants
you'd stand no chance against those.
Well maybe if you yourself grew to be five meters tall,
but that's a story for another, whatever.